what is this happy holidays the white
but do not open it until Christmas
you're so pathetic how long did this
take you three hours five minutes
actually I am a black belt in differe
happing yeah no such thing they don't
give out black belts for things that are
stupid well I hope it was worth it cuz
I'm gonna take it apart in about five
minutes I think I'll take a little bit
longer than that really if I can skin a
mule deer in less than ten minutes I
ought to be able to cut my
[Music]
[Applause]
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best that's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon no here's
going to happen I am going to have to
fix you manage you two on a more
personal scale a a more micro form of
Management Jim what is that called micro
German boom yes now Jim is going to be
the client Dwight you're going to have
to sell to him without being aggressive
hostile or difficult let's go all right
fine ring ring hello
hello this is Dwight Schrute from the
Dunder Mifflin paper company well that's
great because I need paper excellent
then you are in luck because we are
having a limited time offer only on
everything wow this is my lucky day
what is your name sir I am bill but
liquor really that's your real name how
dare you my family built this country by
the way you're respectful too close I
guess Michael you know what imitation is
the most sincere form of flattery so I
thank you any theft is not a joke Jim
millions of families suffer every year
Michael oh that's funny
Michael oh one second that's my other
one what no but I hello
yeah
no I'm just saw the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb probably
it's gonna keep him on the line forever
and not buy anything okay it's up to you
to change mine
sorry that was a family emergency
oh no what's wrong you know what that's
private boundaries white hey hey who are
you
faxing so early in the morning oh um
China who explained I don't have a ton
of contact with his gran branch but
before I left I took a box of Dwight's
stationery so from time to time I send
Dwight faxes from himself from the
future Dwight at 8 a.m. today someone
poisons the coffee do not drink the
coffee more instructions will follow
cordially future Dwight you'll thank me
later as I was saying so we are having a
limit of a little bit louder I'm hard of
hearing
sorry if he's an old man okay as I was
saying right now louder okay our prices
have never been lower when you have to
talk loud never been lower louder son
but maker our prices have never been
lower Hey that is totally inappropriate
you should never yell at the guy no just
listen to me sir here we go
the three words I would describe you as
is aggressive hostile and definitely
difficult please mister by my weight
right you know the phone give me the
phone mr. buttlicker me the phone I have
to put your on with my boss well I
should hope so who is this hello this is
Michael Scott regional manager well this
is William M buttlicker
hello mr. buttlicker how may we help you
Michael I like the sound of your voice
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna buy one
million dollars over the paper products
today CF stop thank you very much sir I
don't think you'll regret it you are the
master there is one condition Michael
yes you have to fire the salesman that
treated me so terribly don't do it
Michael
where is my desk that is weird
this is not funny this is totally
unprofessional okay well you're the one
who lost the desk I didn't lose my desk
okay calm down where was the last place
you saw okay who moved my desk I think
you should retrace your steps okay I am
going to tell Michael and this entire
office will be punished colder warmer a
little warmer Hey ooh warmer warmer
warmer warmer warmer cold cold cold
back up hot red hot very hot Dwight
Schrute hi um what sort of discounts are
we giving on the 20 gee I've given you
this information like 20 times
it's by the ream it is now 978 so it's a
discount 7 okay thank you gotta get back
to work okay so do I in your own words
someone replaced all my pens and pencils
with crayons
I suspect Jim Halpert everyone has
called me Duane all day I think Jim
Halpert paid them too yes five bucks
each and it was totally worth it you
look cute today boy thanks girl
so yesterday Dwight found half a join
the parking lot which is unfortunate
because as it turns out Dwight finding
drugs is more dangerous than most people
using drugs I'm just saying that you
can't be sure that it wasn't you that's
ridiculous of course it wasn't me
marijuana is a memory loss drugs and I
just don't remember I would remember
well how could you of it just erased
your memory that's not how it works
no how do you know how it works knock it
off okay I'm interviewing yo you said
that I'd be conducting the interview
when I walked in here now exactly how
much pot did you smoke this morning I
found a bloody glove in my desk drawer
and Jim Halpert
tried to convince me I committed murder
I think he may be the real murderer Jim
Halpert said there was an abandoned
infant in the woman's room when I went
to save the child
I saw Meredith on the can yeah smile no
I never smile if I can help it showing
ones teeth is a submission signal in
primates when someone smiles at me all I
see is a chimpanzee begging for its life
this came out really well there you go
this is humongous I am NOT a security
threat and my middle name is Kurt not
fart what did I write this morning I
knocked myself in the head with the
phone that actually took a while I had
to put more and more nickels into his
handset until he got used to the weight
and then I just took him all out every
time I typed my name it said diapers
just a simple macro morning Dwight who
are you
Who am I I'm Jim we've been working
together for 12 years
we're joke Dwight you're not Jim Jim's
not Asian you seriously never noticed
hey
hats off to you for not seeing race
alright then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
Wellington systems sold them ten cases
of 24-pound litter stock or were you
talking about Krieger Murphy because I
didn't close that one yet but I'm hoping
I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger
waiting for me please enter your
password
you have one new message no no no no
that is sensitive information only for
employees not Outsiders like cut it out
I'm trying to work you don't work here
you're not Jim Jim I got us that dinner
reservation Riko 7:30 oh great can't
wait
you